[Music]
whatever you give attention to expand
let me say this one more time whatever
you give attention to expand this could
be a good thing or bad thing let me
elaborate let's just be on your way to
work today you got a speeding ticket and
you're fully upset the cops shouldn't
give in to you because you were going 75
in a 65 zone you're upset you come to
work you tell everybody I work about
this thing you text your mom dad brother
sister cousin best friend
boyfriend/girlfriend husband/wife
everybody you're texting I can't believe
what happened then you're putting it on
Facebook then Twitter then Instagram
everybody snapchat everybody knows how
upset you are over speeding ticket you
know what you're really doing just like
a car has a certain amount of fuel to
use for miles your mind has a certain
amount of you to use on what it wants to
give attention to if you use your entire
attention to matter that doesn't do
anything for you it's a waste of time
versus you take that same exact
attention that you have two things that
matter this can turn into something that
can reward you in ways this can never do
for you so let me give you a system here
to use any time you face a lot of
prompts because I'm gonna make a
prediction to you you can have a lot of
times in 2017 here's the system number
one ask yourself can I do anything about
this problem if the answer is no
completely set it aside number two
between zero to ten how important is
this problem to me if it's less than an
eight don't even pay attention to it for
now and last but not least what is my
return on investment if I pay attention
to the speeding ticket what will I be
getting in return nothing if I pay
attention to this problem of my business
what will I get in return
lots of money if I pay attention to this
area of my health what will I get in
return lose weight feel better energy
higher you know dress nice or
everything's gonna be better I want to
pay attention to these things so my
challenge to you is be selective on
which matters you give your attention to
[Music]